cool hey everyone thanks for making it
in this morning I know
you know coming into the early sessions
isn't always the easiest to do so thank
you for finding some time to come hang
out with me and we'll talk a bit you
know about Colin and then a bit about
c-sharp you know when I do this talk it
feels a little more natural to sort of
do it as a conversation because it's all
sort of built around my experience being
a c-sharp developer learning kata and
learning what I can build with it
learning how to build with it sort of
comparing and contrasting a lot of that
so sort of as you guys are following
along with me as I do some of these
comparing contrasting if you have
questions or anything at all throw your
hand up I'm happy to answer them sort of
on the spot if it's something that I'm
gonna get to later you know we'll we'll
talk about that when we get there but
I'll also sort of ask you questions for
to gauge where you guys are at in terms
of what you use C sharp for what you're
interested in using Colin for so yeah so
I'm Alex done on the Internet I'm not
Alex done you'll find me a suave pirate
because my name is so basic in the US
that I'm not the only Alex done that
works with Microsoft technology so even
if you look up Alex Dunn Microsoft
there's like three devs at Microsoft
named Alex Dunn so when I was like
alright I'm gonna start having an
internet presence I started looking up
how I can use my name and stuff like
that nothing without a ridiculous
combination of numbers and letters at
the end so I use a name generator I
wrote when I was like eight years old
boom suave pirate so if you need to find
you'll find me there I'm a Microsoft MVP
for dotnet technology so all the the dev
tools and stuff like that hence the sort
of background in the C sharp space and
I'm also a Pluralsight author and you
know I'll talk about my course towards
the end but most of my Pluralsight
content is around Kotlin so you can sort
of see how doing a lot of dotnet work a
lot of c-sharp work a lot of column work
I sort of have both aspects that make it
really interesting to come do these
talks and introduce a new language so
those of you who haven't used it before
so I want to sort of preface a little
bit that this isn't a hey ditch c-sharp
and use Collins Collins the new and hot
language and it's definitely not I'm
gonna prove that Kotlin sucks and
c-sharp is still awesome I want to sort
of lift both languages up because a lot
of them a lot of the features that you
know you sort of see in both languages
and we'll get into this quite a bit are
very similar and they're both awesome
and we can do a lot with both languages
and I'm hoping in the future potentially
use them actually together which would
be pretty cool so to be a little
specific I'm talking about column 1.3
this is a more recent release so you
know it's it's been interesting as I've
sort of run this talk over the last you
know year and a half I've got to sort of
build on it quite a bit because Collins
growing crazy fast they're throwing
features out like every like three
months or something like that when
they're doing these minor releases so
it's been cool being like oh I can add
this and I can compare how I would do
that in c-sharp versa Scotland and now
you know c-sharp is also growing really
fast I don't know if any of you guys
have messed with all the c-sharp eight
features we'll talk a little bit about
that towards sort of the end but there's
a lot of sort of paradigm between the
two and they both grow crazy fast so how
many of you guys have actually used
Kotlin before or even know what it is
that's actually not bad most of times
it's like someone's like it's me how
many you guys didn't know Collin was a
programming language before you walked
in this room there it is yeah every time
someone's like alright I'm gonna learn
about this Collin framework and write
dotnet no no we're talking about a whole
new language here so let me intro to
Collin a little bit Collin is a
statically typed language it was
originally written for the JVM and it
sort of when I was introduced to Collin
everyone was saying this is what's
finally gonna make you not have to write
Java ever again so I was like alright
I'm invested already it's but it's it's
written quite a bit differently and and
you'll see that as we get to the
examples but you can write it with a lot
of object-oriented style to what it sort
of roots are in you can also write
functional style programming with Kotlin
which we don't necessarily cover in this
because again we're sort of comparing
c-sharp but definitely something worth
worth looking into
and like I said it runs on the JVM but
it does also have a lot of cross
compilation capability so you can
actually compile content to JavaScript
and you can compile it to native which
sort of expands the horizons of it quite
a bit which is pretty cool so column was
invented with pretty pretty sort of
distinct set of expectations right so it
wasn't just there to be another language
it wasn't just there to also get rid of
Java but it was there to help reduce the
verbosity that a lot of Java developers
have to
through how many you guys have written
Java in the last like 10 years or so
yeah see how many of you guys enjoyed
writing Java in the last 10 years or so
okay most of you guys are in the right
place then because we're gonna talk a
lot of trash about Java today so again
the goal is to reduce verbosity so we're
gonna write more efficient code it's
still gonna be easy to read you know
it's not like we're going in and reading
racket and there's parentheses
everywhere or anything like objective-c
which is just terrifying to look at if
you didn't write the code but it's there
to support many different styles - like
I said you can write object-oriented
Kotlin you can write functional Kotlin
you can write procedural if you're into
that and with all of the sort of reduced
verbosity and the ability to support all
these different styles and preferences
it still needs to support backwards
compatibility which means you get a
hundred percent interoperability with
java with anything that runs on the JVM
so you can write you know interconnect
your java your scala your Kotlin your
closure if you're into that and the goal
being like let's just write more code
let's write it faster let's get stuff
out you know we sort of live in a crazy
fast-paced software world right now and
Kotlin does a great job and making it a
bit easier to just get stuff out that's
written well and written strongly so I
like to talk about this there's this
concept in psychology called speech
convergence it basically is like when
you put someone in an environment where
someone speaks either with a different
accent or a different language they sort
of tend to fall into that accident when
communicating with that person and you
guys that have talked to me you might
have noticed me really struggling not to
like sort of copy your accent I don't
necessarily mean to mock it but I'm
super bad at this but we find it
interesting you know looking at sort of
the newer programming languages that
come up they take the routes in other
languages and you can sort of see as new
features are built for one another ones
falling right up maybe they do something
slightly different and I see a lot of
that with c-sharp and Colin at least
from my observations but Kotlin
straight-up says that it brings in a lot
of inspiration from languages obviously
like Java explicitly c-sharp javascript
in scala and groovy and also typescript
as well so if any of you guys are in
typescript you're gonna see a lot of
similarities and sort of the typing
styles and stuff like that and it's
actually how they get stuff to work as a
compilation from Kotlin to JavaScript
with type safety
pull in type script types which is
pretty cool so to start I want to do
some sort of side-by-side so we're gonna
look at the sort of the foundational
stuff you'll see c-sharp you'll see
Kotlin and i want to just sort of get
you guys understanding what the basics
are and then we'll talk about some of
the platforms that they support why you
might actually be interested in using it
and then we'll sort of do a little bit
of a deeper dive into the really cool
stuff all right first things first let's
look at a poco rights the sort of the
foundation of our c-sharp it's the
foundation of our java it's our basic
super basic class right plain ol CLR
object or in this case plain old Java
our plain old Collin object so I'm a big
dog fan I sort of started a Rescue
League and stuff like that so all of
this stuff is gonna be dog related so
just prepare yourself for that
so we have a class named dog it's got a
name it's got an age and it's got a
breed property super basic and c-sharp
we use these all the time in Kotlin this
is sort of what the same thing would
look like we have our class dog it's got
these three properties name age breed
you'll notice the camelcase naming
convention I'm sorry if you don't like
that that's too bad one of the other
things you'll probably notice right away
is that we actually have explicit null
reference types so something that came
out in c-sharp 8:4 knowable reference
types is default in Kotlin there's no
way around it so you have to initialize
something either in the constructor or
in the properties declaration so in this
case all of these are knowable types
were initializing them with null there's
a few different ways you could do this I
won't get into that but for the sake of
the you know seeing them side by side
that's what we're looking at so when
we're constructing our objects we need
to have the same properties and we also
need to have the ability to override
those same constructors so in this case
we have our default constructor and then
we have another one that takes in all
the properties and then we're setting
them right in Kotlin our default
constructor is actually defined in the
signature which you may have noticed in
the previous slide when we had the sort
of open and closed parens it's not
required if you are only going to do a
default constructor with no parameters
but when we override our overload
constructors rather we need to just
define constructor passing the
parameters just like you sort of see in
c-sharp this is some
to other languages to JavaScript class
constructors can look like this and then
the same thing properties all the way
down Kotlin also has this concept of
data classes and you guys go to the
the.net panel yesterday with with Damian
and and David Fowler and stuff like that
someone asked sort of at the end you
know winner record classes coming right
and they were supposed to be in c-sharp
eight that got punted back we have the
idea of records in in Kotlin and we call
them data classes and it's the same as
any other class except you slap the data
in front of it and then in the
constructor you're actually defining
your properties and the constructor at
the same time so this is this whole top
line here is an actual class declaration
it's the definition and it's the
constructor to create it which is really
cool and it's used a lot you can use
this without data classes too you can
sort of just define properties in the
constructor by just giving you either
valid var or something like that
and then we just construct it like this
when we have a data class we get the
hash set automatically we get copy
automatically similar to doing stuff
with structs and c-sharp but we do get a
bit more - one of the other things you
might have noticed is that we have this
sort of concept of Val versus var and
this is also something that's pretty
unique to Kotlin so var being a variable
and Val being a value is similar to
having a read-only property and c-sharp
except that Val and var is sort of a
concept exists everywhere so it's more
like having Constable's var in
JavaScript if you're familiar with that
so value can only be set once when it's
initialized if you aren't initializing
you're gonna get a compiler error if you
try to change it you're gonna get a
compiler error before you can set it at
sort of any time but it does still need
to be initialized at the beginning
that's just how everything in Collin
works so in this case you know we have
our our var name which can be set again
and we also have the value read-only
name and then in this sort of bark
function we are trying to set the valve
to something else and that's not going
to work when we set it at the bottom but
we can set down sound to which is a
variable - something else totally fine
so for those of you who have written
Java you probably know that getters and
setters don't exist and we have to write
and do our capsule
manually we have to have our private
properties or private fields and then we
have to explicitly write getter
functions and setter functions in
c-sharp we have the awesome ability to
write getters and setters which at
compile time actually build the same
similar methods behind the scenes with
sort of the get underscore and the name
of the property but in Colin we also get
the same thing and this actually does
some pretty cool cross compatibility
stuff in order to get this to work in
Java right so everything that we're
seeing happening right now in Kotlin
always still has to work when we're
consuming in Java so although we have a
property here called age and it only has
a getter when we look at this and try to
access it in Java we're actually going
to have a generated function called get
age just like you'd expect in sort of
the similar Java syntax so not only is
it make it cross compatibility across
compatible but we also actually get like
the sort of Java convention of getting
and setting properties with the same
naming convention everything which is a
pretty neat solution they had put
together so in this case you know we
have our dog with a a int age which is
doing a little bit of a calculation
based off of the current date and then
their birthday day time and then on the
same side and column we're doing the
same thing we're doing it yet except you
know Java doesn't have a very good date
object so we're working with that sort
of trash and then doing a whole bunch of
actual math to calculate the difference
but same idea so sort of one of the last
few things I want to talk about in the
basics is just methods and functions so
in this case we have a dog adoption
service it's a class it has two
different methods it has a void method
which is just called adopt dog it's not
going to return anything and then we
have our our method called adopter that
actually returns an object or item that
the object is defined below in in Kotlin
we have functions which we just call fun
because functions are fun they get to do
all the cool stuff so in this case we
have another data class up top again you
can sort of see the verbosity in terms
of like look at how big this C sharp
object is written versus literally three
lines of code that could actually still
be one line of code and Kotlin which is
pretty cool and then we have our
different funds all the way down as you
can sort of see how they're executed one
other thing you're going to notice here
is that the Constructors in
don't use new at all we just call the
name of the class with the parens we
understand that it's a constructor why
do we have to use the new keyword
everywhere we don't need to read so much
while we're writing our code which is
pretty cool another cool thing that
c-sharp does is Lok no coalescing and
propagation so we have both of those
great features so in this case we're
looking at the same dog we have the
breed lifespan and then sort of the
dangerous life span where the life span
is is checking that that breed object is
not null and then checking the average
life span and if not we're gonna return
zero instead we also have the dangerous
one in which case we're actually going
to assume breed is not null if it is
we're gonna get a null reference
exception when we try to access that in
Kotlin because we have noble reference
types from the beginning we have to
explicitly check whether it's not null
or it is no we make the assumption we
make it clear that in this dangerous
lifespan getter breed better not be null
and it's actually a nice sort of signal
when you're reading the code to go okay
I know sort of the dangerous path I'm
taking here I know what I'm playing with
I can work under the assumption that
breeds not going to be no but every time
I'm sort of reading through that code
I'm gonna see the double bang there and
know that I'm making that assumption on
making it hard but we get the same sort
of question mark for the the propagation
that can go through and then the only
other sort of naming convention thing is
instead of the double question marks of
the double ha we get the question mark
and then the colon to do sort of the
same thing it's more like a in-between
turn area that they do so any questions
on sort of the side-by-sides if now I'm
gonna sort of compare and contrast the
platform's that we can build for and
then we'll get into sort of the juicy
bits of the code now cool so a lot of
these are my opinions or sort of what I
see in terms of trends but I sort of
want to highlight what are kind of the
primary developer platforms for c-sharp
do then do the same thing for Kotlin in
terms of what they're pushing and then
also talk a little bit about Kotlin sort
of goals and making sort of this Colin
everywhere work which is it's just
really cool so I always think of asp.net
sort of the primary thing that I see
people using c-sharp for most of my
friends who are c-sharp developers are
writing stuff in asp.net core
how many of you guys use ASP - hey speed
on a core or even asp.net like everyday
yeah exactly I figured I figured a lot
of you would
how about cloud apps so writing
functions running background jobs doing
stuff in Azure that's not necessarily
just a web app how many you guys are out
there doing that with c-sharp okay a
little bit less my calculations are
right
what about windows developers winforms
WPF uwp anything like that
closer and how about xamarin does where
are my xamarin people at I love you guys
all right Kotlin has a number of
different platforms like we talked about
sort of along the same lines you can use
the spring MVC framework which is a Java
framework or you can use from the Kotlin
team this this project called case Orage
is like it's ridiculous it does a lot of
sort of server and client side
communications we're actually writing
Kotlin for javascript that gets compiled
you also have Kotlin for the backend and
you have sort of your api is and
everything else it's really cool those
of you who have used column the like
four of you that are in here and if you
guys mess with that stuff yet or is it
all Android dev yeah I figured okay same
thing with cloud apps if anyone's using
AWS Kotlin is in and especially GCP
colin is finally sort of like coming up
as like a pariah at form to write code
for mostly because it's all the same
stuff for JVM they're just having to
compile it and run it in the same places
you always have and sort of the big one
that I see and this is how I got
introduced to Colin was with Android
development and about two years ago at
Google i/o Google had announced that
Colin is finally going to be one of the
official supported program and languages
for Android development which is really
cool how many you guys have done native
Android development with Java before and
how many of you guys have started to do
it with Colin see this is where this is
this is a transition I want you guys to
make if you have to do it again so
there's a lot of other platforms both of
those supports let's go through some of
the lists in in c-sharp so I would see
we can write stuff on the edge with
c-sharp you can do it with uwp embedded
you can do with some of the new stuff I
don't know if anyone's been following
the the the meadow work that they're
doing with the new boards and stuff like
that which is pretty insane I'm sort of
heavily invested in that I'm really
waiting for my stuff to come in to do
some more IOT and c-sharp
unity we can build really great games in
c-sharp we have the original mono which
is still very relevant and sort of the
backbone of everything from xamarin we
have uno which is a newer platform to
sort of bring uwp everywhere that still
lives sort of on top of xamarin same
idea and of course blazer how many of
you guys have gone any of the Blazer
talks here or taking a look at blazer if
you haven't I recommend it it's it's
pretty insane being able to write
webassembly in c-sharp it feels like
Silverlight but it's not Silverlight so
everything's okay
so Kotlin also supports a number of
platforms and sort of the what I see is
the priority is iOS and I'll show you in
a little bit sort of what I mean with
they're pushing iOS is an actual
platform to build for and like I said
before we can also compile the
JavaScript so that's a pretty important
platform to build for and then anything
native that's using the low-level
virtual machine so we can compile it run
it on the LLVM anything we're writing a
Colin can now basically run anywhere and
then of course anywhere where there's a
JVM
how many of you guys have had to install
Java and you see running on a hundred
bajillion devices worldwide all those
places can also run Kotlin so sort of
looking at that list
the only platforms that like one
supports that the other doesn't in one
way or another is like Windows you can't
really do Colin for Windows yet and JVM
we can't really compile C sharp and run
out on the JVM yet and I can't wait to
talk about that with some of the stuff
and on at 5 but that leaves like
literally everything else that both of
these can support so I think it's
important to know that you know we
actually have options with people that
want to write with good programming
languages if we want to stick to c-sharp
we can do that if we need to venture off
and someone's like hey I really need you
to work on this Java thing you can be
like I'm not gonna work on this Java
thing gonna work on this Kotlin thing
and it's gonna be good and you're gonna
be able to read it and understand what's
going on so cool any questions about any
of the platforms or any reason why you
might want to write in Kotlin cool so
let's get back into the code then I want
to talk about object-oriented
programming it's a very important aspect
in c-sharp especially compared to some
of the other CLR dotnet languages and so
I want to compare that obviously in this
talk to
and it's object-oriented routes so
although I mentioned that Kotlin does
support functional programming I want to
sort of like stray away from that let's
focus in on on the object-oriented bits
and then we'll sort of compare and
contrast that deeper into some of the
cooler features that they both have so
old slide you guys have seen this the
sort of foundation that we need is an
object and so we have the ability to
define our class but let's make sure we
can actually fill in sort of the four or
three depending on who you talk to
pillars of object-oriented programming
so let's go back into your computer
science days and talk about abstraction
we need to be able to create and handle
inheritance we need to be able to do
encapsulation we need to control what
properties are classes functions or
methods are accessible by what or by who
we probably morphism we need inheritance
and we have all of those with both of
them and one of the core things in order
to support this and I'm gonna sort of go
sort of route feature by route feature
here but the first one I always think of
is interfaces so in order to support
things like polymorphism we need to be
able to define interfaces and so in
c-sharp we can do that our interfaces
are simply contracts at least in c-sharp
7 we don't have default implementations
we can do default implementations in
c-sharp 8 and I'll show an example of
that later but in this example we have
our I adoption service and we have our
two methods one that's called adopt dogs
takes in a dog one that's adopt dogs and
it takes in a list of dogs and then we
have an implementation of that that does
the logic of setting the is adopted flag
to true and then another one that loops
over it and calls its own method
therefore adopt dog and Kotlin we do
have default interface implementations
that's mostly because Java had it from
the get-go anyway it's one of the
features that I actually missed when I
first sort of switched over its a
c-sharp from from Java but now writing a
lot of Collin I get that back and it
feels good and in c-sharp eight I get it
which just feels even better so in this
case same deal we have an interface
notice the naming convention we don't
have the I and said we're sort of
sticking with the java naming convention
of the interfaces the default name and
then we slap that in pull on the end
like a monster
so we have our interface we have a top
dog which is
implemented so this needs to be
implemented by anything implementing the
dog adoption service and then we have
the adopt dogs which has the default
implementation it's going to do a four
loop over each of the dogs and the
parameters and then call the adopt dog
which is referenced above it and so in
the implementation we just have to
override the one method we can also
override the the adopt dogs one which
takes in the list but because we have
the default we'll just continue to use
it and so instead we just define adopt
dog as true but now because the
interface knows that there is an adopt
dogs it has the contract of what that
should do it can still reference it
without referencing and implementation
which is pretty cool so encapsulation is
pretty big c-sharp introduced a lot of
different encapsulation keywords that
other languages didn't have so in this
case I'm just throwing a whole bunch of
them in here right so we have a public
class we have a public property which is
a string we have a protected int which
means that anything that's inheriting
from dog can also access that age
property we have private breed which
means nothing but this class can can
talk to it and we also have a private
class within that which then also has a
public property meaning nothing outside
of the dog class can talk to breed and
reference it but dog can reference any
of the public properties within it
Kotlin we have sort of some different
defaults which is interesting so one of
the things you may have noticed when we
were defining properties back at the
beginning is that we're just like var
name boom done default public in Kotlin
not the design decision I would have
made because that you know that's sort
of like letting people worry about what
to secure rather than default secure it
and let them be aware of what they're
making accessible but it does make it
quite verbose since most code is usually
public that people are writing good or
bad we have private same deal only dog
can reference it we have the private
data class breed which then has a public
Val name so the exact same scenario we
also have the same protected same deal
anything inheriting from it can
reference it but there are a number of
other keywords too so in c-sharp we have
the idea of a sealed class meaning that
nothing can inherit from it it's the
same concept as final one of the things
you might have noticed I'll go back for
a second is that we actually have is
open class dog if we want to make
something inherited
that's not an abstract class we have to
actually say that it's an open class
meaning something else can inherit it
default public and final everything in
Kotlin mostly because that's how Java
developers write anyway and I'm sick of
reading public final so we do have the
concept of final which is default you
can still explicitly write it we have
that open concept in Kotlin in c-sharp
we have the idea of virtual which means
that you can override it if you're
inheriting a class that has something
virtual we have internal and c-sharp
which means only anything within its
packages can can talk to it and then the
default which depending on we're using
the default is either private or
basically some form of private for
Kotlin we also have internal same deal
only packages that are that it's in can
talk to it and we also have an idea of
external which is cool it's the exact
opposite right so nothing within the
package can talk to anything external at
first I was like why like who's using
that and then I actually ended up using
it I was working on basically a little
library for people to consume and I
wanted to sort of make all of those
public methods and want people to call
external which is an interesting concept
because then my stuff can't call that
but it doesn't make sense because then
it's sort of defining the data contract
for my library in terms of what people
are gonna do and I'm not gonna mess it
up by using it internally either I don't
know it's kind of cool I haven't really
seen that anywhere else I probably
really didn't even need to use it but I
thought it was a neat concept so on top
of interfaces we have abstract classes
and and I'll answer the question before
it's asked of well if we have default
interface implementations what is the
point of a stupid abstract class then so
in an abstract class in c-sharp we can
actually use it almost like the default
interface does and in this case there
really is no difference we have the
adopt dog which is abstract meaning it
has to be implemented by something
inheriting it and then we also have the
implemented version of adopt dogs calls
the abstract method pretty cool it
doesn't need to know about the
implementation then we have the the
inheriting class of the adoption service
that dog adoption service that actually
implements that adopt dog abstract
method so in Kotlin same exact concept
just like we saw with the
all interface implementations I'm pretty
sure when I wrote this I literally just
like changed it in the slide from like
abstract class to interface but it is
really similar the difference with the
abstract classes is that we can actually
define getters and setters and public
properties and private and protected
stuff in our abstract class that we
can't do in our interface because our
interface can only be aware of
properties that can't reference fields
and methods they need to implement need
to be implemented or funds if you will
so on the not so pretty side of
object-oriented program we also got
static stuff so c-sharp just like every
other sort of C style language we just
slap static on everything so in this
case we have a static class which means
anything in it needs to be static and we
have this static void adopt dog same old
thing right we're just sending a
property colin has an interesting
concept in a naming convention for it
which has been growing on me when I
first looked at I was like what is this
why and and the next one will showed
even more but instead of having like a
static class we actually just have an
object and it makes sense if you think
about it if we have a static class
within sort of a package or within a
namespace when something is basically
referencing that entire package when the
application starts up its initialized
right it's initialized from the get-go
so when you're reading it and Kotlin you
actually think like oh that's just an
object I just always have that sort of
instantiated object and that's exactly
what it is and then when we get into
sort of functional style programming
where we don't even need packages and we
can just like throw stuff anywhere
nothing needs to be in a class this
actually comes in handy so outside of
static classes we can have static
members so in this case we have a
service not static but within it we have
that static adopt and then we also have
the non static instance adop so in
c-sharp all we have to do is slap the
static on the method and then we can
reference it just like we would in the
previous example where we can just say
you know adoption service thought static
adopt versus having to new up the
adoption service to call the instance
method so this is where it was really
confusing for me to pick up at first
because to have a static member on a
non-static class in Kotlin you actually
add what's
all the companion object and it
basically means like hey we've got this
object right it's it's always
instantiated but it's just gonna kind of
like tag along with your class if you
need it one of the things that's
interesting about it is that when you
reference it in Kotlin or if you
reference it in JavaScript when it's
compiled you reference it like you'd
expect to reference a static method
right so in this case here in this run
function we have adoption service ah
static adopt just like we had in c-sharp
but if you reference this in Java you
actually have to call adoption service
companion dot static adopt because it's
actually gonna initialize a static class
within it which is that companion object
which is pretty neat again it was a
little confusing for me at first but for
the concept of having a static member a
static property a static function
something like that on an instantiate
Abul class you just slap it in a
companion object anything you put in
there though is then static so in this
case we only have the one function but
within our companion object that's where
we would put all of our static stuff
rather than having to have like a bunch
of companion objects and each one is
like wrapping the function or property
we just have it once and then everything
in there sort of what belongs to that
companion so one of the things c-sharp
did really well and one of the recent
issue right not an original feature of
c-sharp is extension methods and so this
is where a lot of people I write code
with abuse and they're like throwing a
helper and utility and an extension
method and it'll do all the magic for
you just called dot whatever I think
when it does have a great use case it's
it's amazing to use right so we have
things like link extensions on all of
our collections and all we have to do is
call dot where dot select and it's
pretty great all that's defined in a
separate library than an eye collection
is so in c-sharp we have our adoption
service and we have our existing adopt
dog instance method and then we have to
create a static class to put all of our
extensions in which is kind of
interesting so in this case we have our
adoptable extensions and then we have
that static adopt which then takes into
this keyword in order to tell you that
the dog is the context again and that's
what the extension is being applied to
in terms of the the type in in Kotlin
it's a bit easier to read sort of
following along the lines
of reducing verbosity I mean you can
even just see like compare the lines of
code we're shortening it by like four so
same deal we got an adoption service we
got a public function called adopt dog
it calls dog adopt and we're able to do
that because we just defined this
extension function by just saying this
is a function
I don't care where it is it could be a
not a package it can be it's sort of the
global namespace or it can be in a
specific namespace or it can even exist
within another class it can just you can
just slap it wherever but you just call
adoptable dog adopt and then you define
the function there which I think this is
a really cool way to write extension
methods I don't have to shove them all
into sort of one folder called
extensions and then have one for each
type that I'm building extension methods
for which I know a lot of other people
do and it makes it very terse and very
easy to read and very easy to follow
because now I can also kind of
contextualize my extension methods I can
have this extension method exist only in
this one class that needs to use it it's
no longer this globally accessible
static method that someone can abuse I
can actually scope it properly Kotlin
also has extension properties basically
they're able to do this because of how
they handle again that translation into
an actual method for for things like
Java right so in this case we're
actually giving a Doppel dog a name
property and it's just the calculated
get so you this this can't just be an
open-ended property it has to have an
explicit getter setter or one or the
other so in this case you know we're
combining like a first name property and
a last name property but we can actually
just access as you'd regularly expect to
we can actually also extend can extend
companion objects which is cool and you
can actually see that naming convention
I was talking about where we actually
have to call dot companion but it's
interesting because the same idea like I
saw this as a feature and I was like
what am I gonna do that when am I gonna
need to add a static member to a static
class who's making these rules up and
then I did it once and I was like oh
someone ran into this use case and I
thought of it ahead of time for me which
was pretty cool but again it comes down
to being able to sort of like scope
those extension methods so in this case
if I have the the
need to have a static member called get
shelters or something like that but I
don't want to just allow anyone to sort
of access it I don't want anyone that's
consuming my package to be able to use
it I can actually scope it to a certain
class and define it within a class
that's outside or within a package
that's outside of the adoptable dog
companion object or outside of the
library and I entirely which is pretty
cool
so another thing that c-sharp does
really well is a lot of this sort of
like leaning towards a little more
dynamically typed with a lot of type
inference and stuff like that or even
the disgusting dynamic type how many you
guys actually have used dynamic in
c-sharp a lot okay thanks guys I'm
opinionated on it just because it makes
it a very unstable in certain cases but
doing heavy calculations and stuff like
that it is a lot easier dynamic dynamic
dynamic but you're sort of working under
the assumption that you know what you're
doing which is dangerous but it's also a
lot of fun if you do it right so in this
case you know we have an example where
we're taking in the dynamic pet we can
work under the assumption that it has
this is adopted if it doesn't we're
gonna crash at run time if we pass in
some random class or some object or we
just pass in a string or something
that's not going to work
so Kotlin kind of has this we're again
the same thing you should define as a
dynamic type but this actually doesn't
work in the JVM and that's strictly
because the JVM needs to understand
ahead of time what your types are but if
we're compiling to JavaScript all of our
objects are dynamic no one cares anyway
so if you're writing Kotlin code that's
meant to go to JavaScript you can slap
in dynamic types at any point which is
pretty cool all right let's look at type
inference this is one of the coolest
things so that sort of Java developers
coming to C sharp or like this is the
gross I need to define my types
everywhere but I think it's pretty cool
so in this case right we have a a method
called pet exists and it takes in a
predicate in this case it's an
expression of a func but it could also
just be a function for the sake of the
argument but I did want to show it
because basically when we're when we're
executing pet exists we're actually
making two different type inferences
here because all I have to do is
Piero peed ID equals ID right which is
it's neat I understand what it is
because I can read the code I can go to
Pet exist and I can say oh that is
taking an expression of a funk of
adoptable pet needs to return bool but
it's really terse and easy to read
without having to read through all the
types and everything else so we're
actually making two different type
inferences here we're making an
inference on the parameter type so just
the the the whole expression there that
could just be a funk or it could be an
expression but because it matches either
we're able to just assume that it's
going to be an expression instantiate it
as an expression but then within that
we're also instantiating P as an actual
adoptable pet rather than just sort of
any object which is pretty cool we get a
lot of the same goodness over in Kotlin
which for any of you guys who have
written java recently you'd understand
it like lambda functions aren't a thing
and like they're allegedly gonna be a
thing but Colin's like we're gonna make
it a thing
so some weird things to read here which
makes it a little bit different coming
from a c-sharp perspective so same idea
right we have a predicate and this is
taking in basically a func that consumes
of an adoptable pet and needs to return
a bool so we we define those funks with
the input types as a parameter and then
a little arrow and then what the return
type should be and then on the sort of
execution of that we actually don't call
it with parentheses we define it with
braces almost like we're creating a new
function and that is essentially what's
happening underneath but you'll see it
everywhere where any where you're
passing in a predicate you're passing in
a function you're passing in any sort of
executable code as as an instantiated
bit we're passing it in in brackets
rather than parameters so in this case
we have the brackets pee-peed ID again
we to now work with the type or
inference that this whole thing is the
proper predicate type and that p is an
adoptable pet generics is also really
important and one of the things that
c-sharp in my opinion does a lot better
than other implementations of generics
is these sort of restrictions right so I
can say a pet adoption service of type T
but I can enforce the rule that T has to
inherit from adoptable pet I can enforce
that it has to be a class I can enforce
that it has
the constructor that takes in certain
parameters we can do a lot with that and
we can do all the same things with
Kotlin and in my opinion it reads a bit
better too so you'll even notice sort of
when I had to write this in c-sharp I
actually added a new line in order to
make it fit on a slide but in Kotlin I
actually have a larger font size here
and can still fit it in because I
actually say T has to inherit from
adoptable pet right in the actual braces
where I'm defining the generic which is
pretty cool and all of the types sort of
worked that way but now I can actually
consume T I know T is going to have in
his adopted flag just like we could make
that assumption
over on the c-sharp side and then we're
basically off and running another thing
that is sort of a newer feature in C
sharp is tuples how many you guys
actually use tuples in c-sharp regularly
I love tuples but they they're another
thing that people can abused pretty
easily but in c-sharp I love the way
they define tuples in so in this case
where we have this data parameter that's
going into this adopt method and that
takes in a tuple where the the left type
needs to be dog and the right type needs
to be shelter in c-sharp I can just add
more and more and more types of this so
I can have a tuple of you know 13
different types that I need to pass in I
can name those types I could instead of
just passing in dog and shelter I could
say dog and it is of type dog and so now
I'm gonna have the objects per property
name that I can access but in this case
because I'm not defining it all I have
to do is called item 1 I now know that
is that dog class and so I can hit that
is adopted property so there are two
poles in Kotlin two they actually have
some simple aliases for basically short
handing tuples where if you have two or
three different types you can just call
it a pair you'll notice you get the
first in this case we're using a pair of
same thing dog and shelter and we get
the same sort of aspect where in c-sharp
we called item one in Kotlin where we're
calling just dot first and be called
that second to get the second one that's
pretty intuitive we don't have to have
numbers it kind of makes sense you can
also use the type called triple if you
have three different objects going into
your tuple and you just called off first
that second third and then beyond that
you actually have to just call tuple
type and it's just a generic so this is
actually one where was it was kind of
interesting where they did take a more
verbose approach I'm not sure if that'll
change it in the future once they
realize like other people are doing it
like well we want to be the shortest one
so we'll see but I actually like the
whole pair idea because it reads a
little bit better so I think one of the
most important topics to talk about is
asynchronous programming I'm not gonna
spend a lot of time on it I can spend
days talking about it the session right
after me is gonna do a big deep dive
into co-routines and asynchronous
programming with Kotlin if you're gonna
be around and you're actually still
interested in Kotlin after this which I
hope you are because that means I'm
doing my job
stick around because Ilana's gonna do a
big deep dive in asynchronous
programming which is actually a newer
feature with co-routines that came out
in that 1.3 I was talking about and they
do some pretty crazy stuff but let's
just talk about sort of the the basics
in this case right so in c-sharp we got
async/await
which is awesome we were one of the
first people to implement easy
asynchronous programming made all of our
lives like a hundred times easier I
don't have to care about threads I still
probably should I don't necessarily have
to care about tasks management's
definitely that again I probably should
because a lot of people do it wrong and
in this case you know this isn't
necessarily the the best code but I've
read it to fit on a slide so in this
case right we have an async task called
background get and we're just awaiting
another async task easy in in column we
have this concept called co-routines and
there are extension libraries you can
install which actually give you a sink
awake capabilities but code routines on
their own can do quite a bit and you can
define a whole bunch of different scopes
for your ko routine so in this case
we're essentially saying take the global
scope just add a global code routine and
do it sort of your traditional fire
office async task but I can actually
define my own scopes I can nest scopes
within them I can add extension methods
to these scopes in order to execute
things sort of in a process I can also
within the execution of a code of teen
just say like pause after this things
done alright now continue that coaching
that was in the middle of running and I
can also actually do things like bring
it up in sort of join co-routines
together string them together await them
all just like we can sort of await a
bunch of tasks and stuff like that so
now that I'm done rambling about how
awesome they are this simple example
where we're just calling background get
all we say is global scope dot launch
that's kicking off a new car routine and
then we pass in a method you sort of see
that same thing where I was saying
because we're passing in a function to
be executed we're using those curly
braces we're sort of traditional C sharp
development this would be like passing
in a task as an object we would do it
with parentheses within that launch
function so in a real issue world
example of async await I wanted to take
a sample that I think we're all too
familiar with and that's getting
something from the internet so in this
case I'm mooing up an HTTP client I
don't even care about disposing it I'm
running wild over here my method and I'm
also just calling getstring async I'm
not calling get async I just know what
I'm gonna do I'm gonna take the
performance hit I'm gonna assume all
exceptions are never gonna happen
everything's gonna be good but in this
case I'm awaiting that method which is
just gonna go hit some URL and get me
the string of the response and then I'm
going to deserialize it right and so
then in our background get all I have to
do is have a list then I can kick it off
on a background task which can set the
dog's I have to work under the
assumption that background get is going
to be held by a parent context otherwise
I should have used like tasks factory or
something like that but that wouldn't
fit on my one slide so no way so similar
example with Kotlin we get the JSON from
the URL by intention a URL object and
then we just call read text again
probably shouldn't do this that's a
synchronous call keep in mind and then
basically we're going to use JSON and
like it's it's google's json library
thing like json net in the java world
and do this whole grouse type thing that
I have to do here which is just how JSON
needs to work because Java doesn't
handle certain things very well for D
serialization and then basically we're
actually creating that adoptable dog
type from that JSON and then to execute
that in the background I have my
instantiated list of null for a list of
adoptable dogs and then I'm setting that
in the background after it's been
launched in that co-routine so basically
think of it like something's gonna call
this get adopted dogs and background I'm
gonna watch a KO routine but that get
adoptable dogs and background needs to
hold on to that dogs because my ko
routine is actually going to come and
set it after the fact
which is pretty interesting there is
also the the sort of simple way to await
the curtsy and I just have to take a
reference to that global scope that
launch ID in this case I just call it
tasks because we're all c-sharp
developers and just called dot join and
that's basically going to wait it but
basically because I'm working on like a
current thread sort of my main thread if
you will
I can take my Co routine thread that was
just spun up and then join that Co
routine to my current one so I was
talking about where we can have like
nested Co routines and we can like join
them up to each other keep them all in
the same context and everything else so
I'm done talking about sort of these
default code samples does anyone have
any questions because that was quite a
bit of just code on slides right no
awesome so talking about tooling for
c-sharp developers we have some of the
best IDs in the world regardless of what
language right we get you to use Visual
Studio vs code is there if you're doing
stuff with the CLI we can write C sharp
on the Mac with vias for Mac and yes I
know I need to update these icons to
2019 and we can even use JetBrains Rider
if you've used writer before it's pretty
cool if you use resharper it's
essentially resharper in an IDE I
haven't really used it full time enough
but one of the things I do use is their
Java editor called IntelliJ
it's basically riders like IntelliJ for
C sharp which is pretty cool and they
have a ton of stuff built in for Kotlin
in IntelliJ Android studio which is sort
of the default it's free totally free
Google built it for you
with support from JetBrains which
basically it's living on top of
intelligent with a whole bunch of
Android stuff built in this is sort of
where I started with Kotlin back in the
preview of Android studio 3 and then if
you feel like you can use eclipse with
some stuff I guess so I want to talk
about sort of future state for both
these languages we we've done a lot of
talks about c-sharp eight you've
probably sat in on a few you probably
know some of this stuff but I want to
sort of provide more of that context for
like hey this cool stuff that's coming
out in c-sharp eight that stuff either
already existed in Kotlin or it's coming
out in Kotlin or there's basically some
way to do it that's still
pretty neat so the first things first
Noble reference type I try turning this
on one of my projects and it turned on
warning his errors I don't know if any
of you guys have done that I came up
with like 8,000 errors which is just
gross and I feel like I'm just a bad
developer because that happened but in
this case right we're looking at that
same poco to pojo to poco with a k'
example where instead of just having
default string we're actually explicitly
saying this is a knowable string and so
now it looks a lot more similar to the
cotton example where everything is
knowable reference types from the get-go
we also have the the new concept of
ranges I haven't really used this in
production yet other than sort of
playing with it in the C sharp features
and they're first announced but
basically the idea is I can I can take a
list or any sort of AI collection and
just cast the range to it and actually
loop over that this is another one where
c-sharp did it really well
Kotlin does have the concept of range
and we can define it as a type there
isn't like basically a selector helper
or extension to do it so in this case
I'm defining the range and then I'm just
gonna call sub list grab you know the
first and last thing in the range but
you can do also this exact same thing
we're looking at in Collin and do it in
the c-sharp side where you can define
your range as a variable of range which
is a value type and then sort of carry
on so I've talked about this a bunch of
times already with default interface
implementation so c-sharp we're getting
default interface implementations which
is awesome basically it works the same
way as it does in Java and so it works
the same way as it does in Kotlin and so
now these two are also looking a little
oddly similar we have our eye adoption
service we have a top dog that's not
implemented and we have our default
implementation for adopt dogs that
references up to the one that's not
implemented and then all we have to
implement is the adopt dog single one on
both of those which is pretty cool
asynchronous streams this one I was
really excited about because I do quite
a bit of work with a lot of sort of
real-time data and basically this gives
us the ability to have almost like a
list of available tasks so in this case
where I'll sort of break down the
example we've taken a list of dogs and
we want to get their names in a stream
so in this case I'm just tasked to
laying on each one but then I'm yield
returning each of that into the
and that's gonna return an eye a sink a
newer enumerable of the type because in
this case I'm returning the string name
property and so when we execute that we
can actually just loop over that as you
normally would and we can actually get
that name so each time we're going
through the loop where we're getting to
that get names async again and for each
one in there we're actually waiting to
get that response so we're gonna wait
200 milliseconds it's gonna hit the next
loop cycle
wait 200 milliseconds next loop cycle
and stuff like that c-sharp did this so
amazingly well katli is possible with
Kotlin but as you probably tell this is
getting a little hectic so in this case
I'm actually creating custom scopes for
co-routines and then it's basically
breaking down each of the methods so
have the ability to get a name
asynchronously by creating this this
extension on my co-routine scope and
again just delaying 200 milliseconds and
return the name and then I have the
ability to get those asynchronously
where I'm actually calling like a map
function and I'm calling the async name
so now I'm actually returning a list of
deferred strings knowable strings and
then I can loop over them and I just
have to call that dot await so basically
the the is a little bit more work to do
with it but you can still get that
actual sort of sensation of streaming
each item in the loop because by the
time we get to named oh wait we're
awaiting that full one that does the 200
milliseconds we hop back up and check
the next item in the loop or basically
the difference between the two is then
c-sharp we're waiting when we're getting
to the next loop in this case we're
actually waiting in the loop and then we
go to the next one so Collins got a lot
of stuff going on - there's a lot more
work being done with co-routines it it
launched into production in 1.3 they did
some release like literally two days ago
actually which enhance like a couple of
different things they're doing a lot
more in native development so trying to
get the LLVM stuff to work better doing
more project templates and stuff like
that to work with iOS there's a ton of
IDE enhancements that are always coming
out Android studio feels like they have
another like extension you can use like
everyday so for the xamarin guys out
there did you remember when Miguel was
finally like oh you don't have to in
xamarin Android call find BIID anymore
we'll just get it for you because that
makes sense
we like had that from the beginning with
Kotlin which was pretty cool and what's
being pushed a lot right now and
the cotton community's multi-platform
project so being able to have one code
base that can be your webserver and
share logic with your client-side that's
running in JavaScript which shares
client with your iOS app and your
Android app which all share their same
state logic but just have their
different UI components and stuff like
that and there's a lot of community
projects around that to where we're
getting almost like a xamarin forms
implementation and Kotlin where there's
a shared UI now and then that's being
spread across the different platforms
and all the sort of shared state happens
in a shared library in a shared package
and they're calling that Kotlin
everywhere and I mean like everywhere
like now you can actually come into
IntelliJ just go down to a section for
Colin rather than just going to like
Android I mean like alright I'll do an
Android app and yes I'm selecting Kotlin
because I'm brave in this case we can
just pick up the different project tests
we can do JVM project if we're just
doing something in Java we can do just
JavaScript we can do just native we can
do basically the case where stuff J's
client JVM server we can just do
multi-platform so they give me all of
them and I'll tell you which ones to
delete later you can do mobile with Jess
and Roo and mobile with Android and iOS
and then sort of that shared library for
mobile too and so one of the things I'm
really excited about is a potential for
these to work together and this is
something that you know the last time I
gave this talk like right before build
wasn't a thing I could talk about but
dotnet 5 is coming out in in 2020 and
one of the things that they just kind of
snuck in there and like all the cool
stuff we're gonna get with dotnet 5
better per fan all that I mean they're
like oh but also we're gonna have a
hundred percent interoperability with
Java and they just kind of like toss
that in oh and we're gonna have
interoperability with Swift and
objective-c on iOS and Mac OS and so now
we sort of get this idea where if we can
actually take Java code and then run
that in dotnet we can write in Kotlin we
can write in c-sharp those things can
actually work together and now both of
those together literally cover like
every platform if I can write Kotlin
where I want to and I can write C sharp
where I want to I can also then stay on
top of what features I want to be
working with and I'm I'm really excited
about this I'm hoping that you know by
the time don''t 5 comes out we do have
that that implementation of the
interoperability because I'm gonna be
jumping on it and building tools to
connect these two because
I'm so torn between them all the time I
really have a talk because I'm so torn
between them like someone write cotton
with me please okay
let me summarize what happen both these
languages are awesome right
it can anyone agree with that cotton one
seems pretty cool anyone who hasn't used
cotton before think cotton seems pretty
neat anyone who's like nasty sharp is
still better I don't care yeah I get
that but one of the things I want to
emphasize is that like we we've really
did just barely scratch the surface with
Kotlin here we didn't talk about any of
the functional stuff we didn't really
talk about design patterns and and how
easy they are to implement in cotton we
didn't talk about some of the deeper
language features we barely scratched
co-routines we didn't talk about doing
the async oh and I'll wait with
co-routines we didn't talk about anko we
didn't talk about Native I didn't show
you demos of it I just showed you code
snippets so if you want to learn more if
you're interested in the Android side
I've got a Pluralsight course called
building Android apps with Kotlin
getting started we do a whole app from
the beginning assumes you know nothing
about Android and assumes you know
nothing about Kotlin and you get to
actually build a real-world app which I
won't spoil too much about so resources
for this talk every little code snippet
that was there that's up on github so if
you want to see that compare and
contrast I have both projects in one
repo clone it look at them both pull
them up in code there's there's Collin
extensions for code too if you feel like
just looking at it all in one place
which is cool check out the Pearl site
course I have a whole blog series on
this stuff too specifically for c-sharp
developers so doing a little deeper dive
on comparing a single weights of Koh
routines and stuff like that and I'll
put all these slides up on Twitter too
it's it's up there from like older talks
but I want to get the updated stuff and
if you're gonna stick around hang out
first fit Lana stock you know like I
said Kerr teens are sick and and I'm
gonna be hanging out here too so I'm
gonna go out and grab a drink if I
didn't want to come and ask me questions
I'll be in here for this talk and learn
a lot more about co-routines and
asynchronous programming and Kotlin
thanks guys
you